everybody comes back to school full-time
in september
it's our moral duty as a country it's
absolutely safe for children to go back
to school it's all reopening
in september outbreaks of the infection
across the country
[Music]
it's a sight that wouldn't raise an
eyebrow at the start of this year
but now many parents will be concerned
about their children returning to the
hustle and bustle of school
as evidence around the transmission of
coronavirus stacks up
these are the top three things you need
to know
less than five percent of overall kovid
19 cases across
europe and the uk are among children
very few
significant outbreaks of covid19 have
been observed in schools
but they do occur and may be difficult
to detect
because children are more likely to have
a mild infection
or not show symptoms at all meaning that
the infection
may get undetected or undiagnosed
what have we learned from other
countries
it's still early days for most countries
who have put kids back in classrooms
but it appears most have avoided causing
big outbreaks
they've taken different approaches for
example denmark have staggered the
return to class
allowing kids back in waves whereas
israel
rapidly reopened schools denmark saw
an initial increase in cases when it
reopened classes for younger kids
but then a decline in israel there was a
consistent increase when schools
reopened
it has since closed hundreds to control
further outbreaks the general wisdom
appears to be
that schools are safe to reopen in
communities with low
transmission rates and the european
center for disease control says that if
the right social distancing and hygiene
measures are applied
schools are no more risky than other
places of work
or leisure settings many of which have
already been allowed to reopen across
the uk
will they put elderly relatives at risk
early studies show that children
aren't the super spread as they are with
the common flu
in fact a review of children and
coronavirus transmission in sweden found
that although
children are able to transmit the virus
like anyone else
they seem much less likely to do so
can kids be kept at home the short
answer is no
nearly all children of legal school age
will be expected to return to class full
time in september in scotland
england wales and northern ireland this
includes those with special educational
needs and disabilities
and those who have been shielding the
schoolkeeper can measure it up so if you
move those
we can get this done really quickly
still worried
all of the four nations have published
their guidelines for schools reopening
head to the relevant government website
to find out more about
what's in store
you